[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
jeff van gundy is on the call somehow we
make the segway jeff van gundy is on the
call for the eastern conference finals
he was in miami last night now he goes
up to boston as the series
shifts to boston uh
jeff welcome uh
sounds like the show's already in
progress right um earlier i was talking
about danny ainge when he was the gm of
the celtic he traded down they won the
lottery he traded down even though he
loved jason tatum and i was wondering
why would you risk losing jason tatum
because what if the lakers took jason
tatum instead of lonzo ball uh
philadelphia loved markelle fultz but i
was wondering that as i'm watching tatum
last night everybody looks at him and
goes he's a superstar first-team all-nba
but
why do you think danny ainge ran the
risk of maybe missing out on jason tatum
well in retrospect it was a brilliant
move because he got
added compensation he probably knew that
the lakers were going to take ball
and that
from what he
gathered they were going to take folks
and when you look back
you know and these are the hard things
about
drafting
it looks like a no-brainer now
but back then i don't
i don't remember anybody saying oh yeah
it's a no-brainer that
jason tatum
is should go one and
you know but now
it looks ridiculous that philadelphia
did what it did and the lakers did what
they did
all right let's get to last night's game
at at what point does eric spoelstra
like can you say anything to have your
third quarter can he say anything to
help them shoot better
no i think
when you are
in a funk like they are shooting right
now
and really playing you know they have
not played well
um since the
third quarter of
you know what game three yeah yeah
they just haven't played well they
haven't shot it well
um
and and frankly dan i i think
they're not as talented
as boston is i think boston is the most
talented team left in the in the
playoffs
i think their size is overwhelming
right now when robert williams is
available
i just don't think they have good
matchups and if jimmy butler can't get
going
um with tyler hero out i just don't see
how they have any chance
of extending the series
as a coach
how can you
differentiate between that guy is going
to be our number one option that guy's
our number two option that guy's our
number three option
and
i point this out because jason tatum is
the star jaylen brown has to know his
place and then marcus smart has to know
his place easier said than done but as a
coach how do you do that where everybody
sort of knows like pippa knew his place
with jordan um
you know you go down the michael knew
his place with bird i mean the the game
is littered with players who understand
their role but it gets tricky when
somebody thinks they're better than what
they are so
how do you get jaylen brown
to understand hey as long as you're the
second option uh we're great don't try
to be
the number one guy
well i don't know if you have to
differentiate it like that where what
you're trying to do is maximize the
strengths of your all your players
and
what i think is hard to do though
is not have uh
the insidious nature of jealousy
when someone like tatum is first team
all-nba
that you're not jealous of that and
then that takes
you down a bad path as as a player
jaylen brown has been outstanding in the
in the playoffs and he's had a terrific
year and
there's nothing he should not compare
himself to tatum he should just like
he's on a great path himself
but a lot of players
get
you know whacked out about
it's not even the player sometimes the p
the people
around the players
always want their guy to have more to
get more recognition um
and that's where to me where milwaukee
they've done a great job though
you know everyone knows giannis is the
the guy and middleton and holliday
they play
great basketball but there's no jealousy
there's
you know no insidious relationships and
i think boston hopefully is achieving
the same thing
we're talking to jeff van gundy he's
been on the call eastern conference he's
got game six heat celtics tomorrow night
in boston you have tonight the golden
state warriors in the dallas mavericks
if you're jason kidd what's your
approach tonight in san francisco
well they've been in good shape in most
of the games they had
obviously in game three a horrendous
shooting night
but when you have someone as good as
doncic
you always have a shot
and
i don't expect them to to win tonight
but i do expect them to play an
outstanding game
uh i think they're gonna play hard
i think they've done some really good
things throughout the series
and
if doncic
can get into the paint and collapse the
defense we'll get good shots and if they
can get good shots and make enough
they'll be in the game into the fourth
quarter and have a puncher's chance
you like golden state or boston
i like boston i've liked boston
um since the start of the playoffs i
just think
their
size uh
the high-end talent
um i thought they made some great
uh trades
so their depth
and then their defenses just
otherworldly now that that is if robert
williams can remain
somewhat healthy i think he's that
important to their overall success
if i said you had to make a choice you
can either keep kyrie if you're coaching
the nets or you can keep james harden if
you're coaching the sixers who are you
keeping
i don't know i think it's hard to
determine that yet because
you didn't see harden for very long in
philly i think both teams
have
championship aspirations they need those
two guys to have enough talent to be
legit championship talented teams and
yet they both bring
dilemmas
to their respective teams
that
you know
are not necessarily easy to resolve so
these are all the tough choices you know
people that talk about oh we they should
let him go you know like kyrie let him
go right well you don't have enough
talent then if you let him go
to win a championship so
um
i think the thing i you know i think
both teams
um
kick those guys because without them
they have no chance to compete for
championships i'll leave you with this
kevin durant was asked last week the
center from the 80s or 90s who would
flourish in today's nba
who would you pick
the centers from the 80s or 90s yeah who
would flourish today oh
a lot of them like
because the game would change if you
have that level of talent you know ewing
elijah one robinson
shaquille o'neal jabbar like they'd all
be dominant right now
and people that
don't understand greatness
um
most people would absolutely
uh
be great today because
greatness
through greatness
is able to play
any style and any era
i picked akeem he's one of my favorite
players i think he's one of the more
underrated players if that's possible
well
if people are underrating him they
probably never saw him the
combination of
defensive ability
and then offensive he could make a
17-footer he grew as an nba player he
became a much better passer
and then his his footwork
like in the post
uh was something to behold he would
he would be dominant in any era i don't
i don't know if
if elijah won if you've seen him if you
could underwrite him he was just that
good
safe travels jeff thanks for joining us
you got it thanks dan jeff ann gundy
he'll be on the call for the mothership
eastern conference final uh eastern
conference finals now shifting to
boston